what was the first thing you did in
fallout 4s character creator if your
answer isn't make the ugliest face
possible or see if I could make mr. bean
then you're not doing it right
we've tried to make Kim Kardashian
Geralt from the wit show the game spot
team and all of the Disney Princesses
and all that we've learned is that we
should not be plastic surgeons but the
talented fallout 4 community have been
busy at work creating some pretty
impressive celebrity faces so we don't
have to the fallout 4 community
continues to put the games character
creation tool to good use famous people
real and fictional like Kanye West
Taylor Swift louis c.k and walter white
have now been brought to the wasteland
by some creative and committed players
last week fallout 4 players showed off
characters based on people like Trevor
from Grand Theft Auto 5 Carol from The
Witcher and nigel thornbury smash people
also made Vladimir Putin and Hitler
characters vicars of course they did
have you made any impressive
recognizable celebrities in Fallout 4
what do you think of the game's
character creation tools in general let
us know in the comments or come and find
me on twitter at how not to draw i'm
kate and remember to keep it
gamespot.com for all your gaming news